let me show you something cool in chrome
dev tools we can easily open up the
source code for a website all we need to
do is open up dev tools which I'll be
doing by pressing command option I and
then we'll go to the sources pain here
in sources we can see all of the source
code that led to the website we see
behind us so index.html should look
pretty familiar and we can open up Java
scripts and we can see helper j/s jQuery
and resume builder j/s let's open up the
helper j/s over here we can see it let's
give ourselves a little bit more room
and I'm gonna scroll down inside helper
j/s we've got all of the strings
containing the HTML we wanted to add to
the page and we can find some functions
down at the bottom this Java Script down
here is actually creating the map that
we see on the page but there'll be more
on that in a little bit for right now
let's pay attention to this line right
here inside this function called
location finder we see this statement
that says return locations we've seen
this return keyword a few times so far
but we haven't really delved into its
purpose yet it's called a return
statement and its purpose is to make the
function give back a value I think I
know what you're getting at won't you
explain it a bit more well remember
console.log it doesn't return anything
which means that if we were to create a
new variable like this var hello equals
console.log hello will get undefined
when we try to run it we see that
console.log worked and printed hello but
then we also see this undefined below it
if we try to examine the variable later
by just typing out hello and pressing
enter we see undefined
that's because console dot log didn't
return anything it didn't give anything
back
however most functions actually do
return values like a lot of string
methods yeah let's look at string dot
split first we'll create a string like
this one I've created a string called my
string and I've set it equal to this is
my favorite string then we're going to
go ahead and separate this string on
spaces meaning that we'll get each word
by itself split works like so it's going
to act on the string here and it's going
to separate it based on the parameter
here this parameter is just a single
space so we should get an array of
words from my stream let's go ahead and
save it to the variable my array and
press Enter
okay and when we try to access my array
we see an array of strings this is my
favorite string each of the words from
my string before in other words split
returned an array of strings which is
now equal to my array oh I see when we
write functions that we want to turn
into a value they must give us back a
value looking at this function as a
whole the parameter is the input the
function does something using that
parameter on the actual string and then
it gives us some sort of value let's
think about the resumes JSON data and
all of the locations in it for this quiz
I want you to write a function called
location Iser that's going to take in
the work object location Iser
should return an array of the locations
from your work object remember work
contains all the jobs that you've had in
the past and each one of which should
have a location associated with it we
want you to return an array of those
locations you might find it's helpful to
use the array dot push method which is
going to add values to the end of an
array when you get to the quiz you'll
see a sample JSON that your code will
iterate through good luck